Britain's iconic red telephone booths
are making a comeback payphones have
fallen out of style in the cellphone era
well now people are finding imaginative
new ways to make use of the relics mark
Phillips is in London with the Second
Life for many of those classic phone
booths mark good morning
good morning well these things have been
part of the British landscape for about
80 years but the question is when is a
phone booth not a phone booth the answer
is now
[Music]
the British famously have trouble
letting go of old things
the monarchy double-decker buses
taxicabs that look like they were
designed sixty years ago because they
basically were but when the cellphone
turned the classic old red phone booths
they used to adorn what seemed like
every street corner into a waste of
space there was a problem what to do
with them as nobody was using them the
phone company started taking them away
they come here too it looks like a phone
booth graveyard except it's not
it's a magical transition zone to a
second life your job was just to collect
them get rid of them yep tell you boy
they're gonna be played Tony English ran
a trucking firm that got the contract to
remove the old phone booths many of
which had fallen into ruin but something
happened then you thought wait a minute
just go so Tony started fixing them up
and surprise surprise people started
buying them some because they liked the
old phone booths with their quaint old
phones where the operator told you how
many quaint old shillings and pence to
deposit so I did what I do push it down
put you down that's telling be playing
with old phones however only went so far
well you've proved these booths that
turned out had legs
Tony's refurbished more than 2,000 of
them others started showing up around
the country being put to all sorts of
new uses that old booth on the village
green turned out to be a great place to
put a defibrillator local libraries
found them handy places from which to
run book exchanges how about a coffee
shop
they were already in prime retail
locations or a hat stall florist salad
bar or an antisocial disco and perhaps
the most ironic use this one operates as
a cell phone repair shop
how's that for recycling the things are
already popular few tourists come to
town without the mandatory selfie in
front of one of the ones still around
that they'd be a natural place to do
business seemed obvious to Eddie Otto
well who started renting them out they
seem to have an attraction as you can
see but exactly what is it about these
things just they just start going they
the read find books of the history their
poem proves like being through wars like
being proof you know you mean they've
been for everything the booths were
famous for one other thing they were a
natural advertising place for escort
services still are apparently how longs
it take you to get the escort service
cards out of the ANC's ones we used to
rake up like autumn leaves stacks of
these things these weren't just phone
booths they were cultural signposts and
they won't go away in fact many of them
can't be moved they've been declared
what's called listed culturally and
historically significant buildings just
as well John that they found other uses
for them thank goodness Mark Phillips in
London for us those are I love those I
know they bring back memories right
they'll be there will be some people
that will look at them and go what is
that how does that work and you all know
nobody tells it better than mark yeah
it's